hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark wood
now we have a job to do a job that
likely involves
some village purging
i'm not sure if i'm gonna have to kill
everybody but that seems to be the
general inclination of what's going on
here
but it's to save the grandma and the kid
which is a noble cause so i'm gonna do
that
also it seems like if you make a pump
action shotgun it starts out fully
loaded
so technically speaking so long as i
have enough weapon parts
if i run out of the shotgun shells that
i do have and i imagine that when i
reload it's going to use up pretty much
all of my shotgun shells but i imagine
that i could make more
if i make another which technically
speaking means that i now have a reason
to buy the weapon parts from this person
are these three persons if they're even
people are they people
doesn't really matter that's fine so i'm
assuming
i have to kill all of the villagers
which seems really mean i mean i killed
their pig
first off which was necessary but you
know
still probably mean and number two
they're already starving
they're afraid they're in a weird place
you know yadda yadda i could actually
use that again if i get another
shotgun what
is that deal what is the deal with that
something's clearly happening over there
is there a way to get oh my god there is
isn't there
oh oh hey how you doing
yeah okay well you're dead now oh no no
no no no no no no no
still hate that still hate it oh hey a
crate
interesting well not really worth it but
i take the run pills this is what
happens every morning
i waste time because i'm like oh look at
this oh look at this damn this game for
having so many interesting things to
look
at damn it to hell
huh oh hey bud oh ow
right right you're the weirdo
what the hell
gotcha well
[Music]
hey it's me again
what's up hey how you doing i took your
potatoes
hope you're all right don't worry just
weirdo with an axe coming through
oh stones actually i i need those to
check bodies because i'm pretty sure
some of the bodies might have ammo i
haven't checked a single body
yet don't mind the ax murderer coming
through your
town just gonna murder something
whomp okay never mind womp
okay this guy he's gonna be ow i'm up
against a tree i'm up against the tree
ow
sorry man look it's the law of the
th something it's some law some law
somewhere says that i need to do this
because you guys were looking at a
grandma funny and i
no one appreciates that you think that
guy's still across the way
is he going to be a problem oh mommy
sorry
he's tough
not that tough oh man do i have to kill
them all
this doesn't feel good this feels very
wrong
i mean they are starving and it's my
fault and maybe i shouldn't have done
that and maybe i'm just paying for
what was already clearly my fault but
hey
still don't feel good oh god he gets up
quick
your reaction times are nuts you stuck
he's stuck
sorry dude oh this feels bad
i guess i can put them out of their
misery
oh they're infected anyway
oh this feels bad oh sorry
is that the last of them i don't hear
any more coughing
there's only the guy that's across the
gap hi
hello i don't know if this is necessary
oh my god oh my god i feel
terrible god why did i do anything
man i just think i feel like in this
whole playthrough i've made just
the worst decisions ever and i'm i'm
reaping what i sow and i'm sewing what i
reap feels bad man feels bad feels very
bad man
i'm a bad man and i feel bad all right i
grandma
grandma grandma i literally killed
everybody
literally everybody i killed literally
oh god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
i'm just gonna run just gonna run just
gonna run
i have powers too why would i never use
my powers
what is this where am i what is
what is this okay
need a key i guess i could bash it open
oh man that's a tough door oh never mind
not tough at all actually
uh not really what i was hoping for it's
a little extra goodies
maybe there's something up there oh hey
gas tanks i'll take them hi grandma
hi it's me hey how you doing and what
news have you gotten rid of the greedy
mom that wants to get
me yes i have the old lady smiles
revealing her white toothless gums
she leans in her arm chair and grabs him
by the hand heartily i feel a white
goose seeping from her hand smelling of
mushrooms
you're a good man honey the woman
produces a small key from under her
skirt
here take the boy to his family he'll
probably be safer there
and come back tomorrow i'll give you a
beautiful gift for the trouble
oh okay all right cool
oh awesome hey
hello hi hey
note oh scary
okay
wow the boy is standing under a wall of
overgrown with enormous mushrooms
he's visibly scared his lush mop of hair
veils a restless wide open pair of eyes
the kid is whispering as if reciting
something under his breath the boy
cowers and presses his back against a
soft wall which starts to ooze with a
white goo
kneel and extend your arm towards the
boy leave the boy in peace
well this is why i'm here the boy is
terrified slowly he slumps down from the
wall to the ground curling into a ball
the murmur turns into one loud
recitation
one little buried a bowl of soup then
another bear came and there were two
four little bears made a sudden pow
along came the fifth and took a little
bow
okay numbers one two four fifth
one two four fifth when i take the boy
into my arm he starts screaming reciting
the rhyme over and over
one little buried a bowl of soup then
another bear came and there were two
four little bears made a sudden pow
along came the fifth and took a little
bow
this is going to be a long journey
oh go oh there we go oh that's good you
brought back my child
the woman leans towards the boy marcin
where have you been
the boy stares at the ground in silence
come here
marcinek walks towards the woman
nervously plucking at his old torn
sweater
look at you where's your mask and the
gas tank from your gracious brother
his love protects us it fills our lung
with clean air
and this is how you thank him young man
your childish behavior made him very
very angry
now we will all have to apologize to him
for your stupidity
the two kids standing behind their
mother flinch the woman grabs the boy's
hand and disappears in the hallway
after a while she comes back with an
oxygen tank
take it it's a tank for you it will
protect you from this devilish air
the devil's breath and other evils
lurking in this foul place
it's the only thing i have and the only
thing i can give you the tank is a
little rusty but it seems intact
on the side you can see some
unintelligible scribblings the valve
opens with a little resistance but i
don't hear the hiss fare
it's empty don't open the valve without
need you will only waste the clean air
she pushes my hand away from the valve
and closes the hastily may it serve you
well
oh their tanks are empty
i didn't even think about that oh wow
need the key one little buried a bowl of
soup
none of my keys fit i guess they took
away the key okay one
one two four fifth it's the code
to the house where the flowers lead
hey thanks thanks for the uh oxygen tank
you dummies one two four oh wait the
door's up oh wait no this door was
already open
i wish i had light one
two four fifth
one two four fifth i can't see anything
i don't have any light do i
oh what is the sound there's dreadfully
rancid
and stuffy the heavy sweet smell of
flowers mixes with this stench of rot
oh
corpse probably have a young boy empty
oxygen tank
i don't need two do i need two
is there a problem if i get this why why
would
why would there be more than one way to
do that do i need two the pages are
glued together creating a rotten clump
of paper there's a note at the bottom
radio tour
tower door 12 12 p.m kowals kowalski
stell mazusk at the top i can only make
out the words devil horns organ
the rest of the words are unreadable
interesting
well now i have two tanks
i thought i all right i got two tanks
they're empty so i need to fill them so
there's got to be something
with this lake about filling these tanks
and getting in there that's what it's
got to be about right
that makes sense oh it makes sense
it makes almost too much sense awfully
convenient this whole
i really appreciate it wish the other
zones had something like this
how you doing bod hey pal look it's been
great
leans over oh the violin lying next to
his overgrown left hand he plucks one of
the strings with his right hand
clumsily trying to keep the rhythm i'm
sorry for asking but
do you maybe have something to eat the
boy stops strumming he carefully sets
the violin down between his knees and
holds his neck
i'm a wee big hungry and if he had
something anything
uh i got i got potatoes yeah yeah yeah
yeah i got potatoes
yeah yeah man of course i got you
hey i was worried you wouldn't come back
i have potatoes potatoes
i don't have the dead rats you gave me
oh [ __ ] but i
i i just i i would i would gladly give
you
i i would what what i will give you the
potato i have potatoes
but you don't want you want a dead rat i
don't know where to get a dead rat
i really don't i don't know where i
would get that okay hang on i
i i have an issue i'm trying to oh
though i pushed that right out of the
place where i placed it i
i i have a little bit of a uh a problem
um refilled all the empty oxygen tanks
okay i now have two
filled tanks okay um i don't know where
to get a rat
i will give you a dead rat i wouldn't if
i hadn't known that you wanted the dead
rats i would have saved them for you
i would have given you all the dead rats
you wanted do you
want a mushroom maybe there's a mushroom
in here maybe a mushi
you want a mushy i can give you a mushy
wait do i have a mushy i don't have any
mushies
drink the water in the well i'm glad
you're back i'm glad i'm back too
oh also about your village um uh they
might not be okay
but that's okay i'm your friend okay do
i have time to do anything
um i can make another pump action
shotgun you know i'm gonna do that
clear up some of my inventory for a
sweet another pump action shotgun
i've got this single shot with one
bullet in it i don't know if i'm gonna
need it but i've got it
i have no gas oh god
oh no oh no oh oh no
oh no oh no
this might be a rough night
okay i'll be fine
i'll be fine
what what
what what is that
what is that
what is that oh this this really is
oh oh god okay hang on wait this is why
i did this
where'd you go where'd you go
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
you are going to get a shotgun
oh my god i'm going to die oh my god no
i'm trapped help me ah okay
i'm dead
well that's one way to make it through
the night i
i don't have nearly as much stuff oh no
wait
i'm okay you got any uh
gas thanks thank you
thank you okay yeah that didn't go
nearly to plan and not for the reasons
that like it was
it should have that was just bad
uh is the musician still okay hey how
you doing
hey good to see you i was worried you
wouldn't come back of course
of course i would of course i would come
back
i'm here for you would you like a toy
maybe i could give him the toy what if i
gave him the toy
do you think he'd like do you think he'd
take the toy i got a toy you want toy
is it you show item no he doesn't want
to see the toy
oh man i feel bad no they don't want to
buy the toy either the toy must be
for something specific but i just don't
know what it is you could dig the embryo
though
i don't even want that let me see if
he'll eat a mushroom maybe if i give him
a mushroom he would like that
marjoram would you like a mushroom maybe
i should give it to the boy he must be
hungry
give it to him yeah oh thank you mister
you're so kind
but i don't have anything nothing i can
give you
the boy leans over his left side and
reaches for something with his right
hand i hear some
porn fabric he passes me a piece of rope
which was part of his tattered clothing
it's it's a kind of rope you can do a
lot of things with rope you can do a
knot
tie it or hang your laundry on it you
didn't need to do that i didn't want
anything in return
so sad at least you got something
all right okay i'm i'm i gotta go i
gotta go that night didn't go so well
but i guess you know dying made it
end sooner so hey if i want to get the
night over with i just
die there's probably some lingering
consequence for that okay but i got two
oxygen tanks and there's a lake
apparently and i i thought i was in the
lake before but apparently i was not in
the lake
the lake is not where i was i was in
something that wasn't the lake there was
also something else there was some other
place
that i could i remember there was a dive
it wasn't here but i'm gonna check the
lake first but it wasn't here
where was it where was that there was
another thing wasn't there am i crazy am
i not remembering right i need a light
i'm not remembering right am i what was
it there was a thing
i distinctly remember a thing
oh what the hell
what the hell what
what the hell what is this
how is there more nightmares every time
how are there more nightmares every
single time
i thought i've seen everything and then
all of a sudden
oh more food for the kid i guess
huh
what the hell is this
what the hell no no no no oh my god okay
you're getting a show oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god both of you
where are you oh my god
oh my god oh my god
who else is there who's there
okay okay okay okay okay okay
oh my god i'm out of ammo oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god i scream
reload heal up my god
my goodness my goodness gracious
come at me come at me where are you
where are you there you are
there you go that's what you get that's
what you get oh my god
what is this nightmare what is this
what is this supposed to be how many
more
how many more just you just you oh two
of you
okay that's one down and
two oh i love this shotgun
i love i don't need more i haven't
needed wire in so long but i still love
this shotgun
the shotgun is the tits oh
there's a well why is there a well here
oh what is that
[Music]
what is that
what is that oh what is this oh god hate
that
hate that hate that you know what oh
yeah
oh god oh god oh god oh god yep yep oh
god oh god
yep okay okay ah oh my god where the
hell
what fresh hell
okay all right so something
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
okay one down two
where are you oh my god oh my god oh i'm
out of bullet
okay wait wow wait run and then
run one run oh oh my
god
what the frick was that place
they took my tanks those jackasses
oh my god
oh my god all right i gotta go get my
tanks back
i gotta go back ah i was not
look i can take on like one of those
maybe
two but how many are there
how many jackasses do i need to
shoot oh hi corpse
you know actually i'm gonna preemptively
take that preemptively take the antidote
i don't know
screw it that's all i got
oh that's unpleasant
that's unpleasant so like the wind is
coming out of that
thing i hear him where are you at where
are you at come at me
there's a couple of them
just where's my bot there's my body
okay all right so what else is here
i don't know where they are where is it
there there yeah yeah yeah
moving moving moving statement oh my god
there you are boom
yes dead get oh my god another one okay
there's some kind of black goo on it
boom okay
you dove in front of the other one like
a hero you're trying to save your friend
and
in the end it did nothing what is this
what is any of this tractor
rusty tractor overgrown with bunch of
thin roots great
good why why
oh god not an oh my god okay boom
okay it's just a dodge enough maybe i
just
kill this thing
did it do anything
nope i don't think there's some i'm on
fire
water where's the water i'm i'm in water
go oh my god stop that
oh such an idiot okay um what is
do what i uh so confused
i'm so confused wha why
is any of this meaningful i don't need
medium but i never should have sold that
gun
if i'd have known how many gun i would
need metal door
seems to be blocked from the other side
what do you mean block from the other
side where am i
i don't know is it the tractor was it
the tractor that was
is that the tractor
oh hey i god i
don't know why i haven't learned my
lesson
oh good what the frick protection gets
put
oh that's handy that's very handy
oh that's that's handy oh and there's oh
there's just it's just supplies is that
it
oh my god get me out of here what the
hell you stupid
thing i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm
leaving i never should have come here in
the first place i'm leaving
grandma said to visit her i'm gonna go
say hi to grandma
she was gonna give me a present wait i
got the boots did the boots work like um
wait hang on oh
oh screw here oh
oh wait oh no resistance wait did that
because i took the
when did i take that is it the boots it
said poisonous substances on the ground
i'm thinking it was the boots hi grandma
screw
scrooge how you doing hello
received all received sweater i made
this for you
here you go the woman grabs a thick wool
and sweater from behind her chair and
gives it to me
winter is coming they serve you well
oh my goodness
oh oh my god made a stranger prevents
blood oh
oh i'm wearing armor it's armor oh
oh oh oh oh that's so nice
i got my boots though i wish i had
gotten this ten thousand years ago but
no
that's oh my goodness
what no what whoa oh hey how you doing
uh
let's let's i've never mailed you ow
what the hell you weren't so bad
you're not so bad have i been in here oh
yeah it's the weird
it's the thing oh i wonder if you have
to like shoot
oh maybe uh this is this i wonder if
this is why these are here because i
could probably place this
uh i don't know why i'm wasting time
doing this but it feels good
it feels good to have control over
something in my life if i put this here
and then shoot it
it'll blast open the obstacle on the
other side of that door
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay that's not what i was
hoping for
oh my god guys will someone please give
me
anything although i will take these
because i i might need to make another
you know shotgun but at the same time
will someone give me bullets
they've given me so many other things
but not bullets there was something um
oh hey bud how are you doing i haven't
seen one of you in a while
ow hang on sorry man
there was something over on the left oh
no
no no no no
there was something on the left here yes
the hole
the hole i have oxygen tank
sploosh i have this is it
oh my god yes oh my god yes
yes where am i where am i
i thought time might freeze if i entered
this but it did not okay
okay ooh ah e i o e o great
wow that's really something
maybe i could fix this and get out of
[Music]
here
okay hello
so uh what about this
is it just a cool place to be oh hey
oh oh oh oh
oh oh wow
oh wow that the only thing wow i gotta
go
i gotta go wow
wow wow ah
oh wow i gotta go i gotta make it to the
hole in two hours
oh wow and then i gotta fill up the
gender oh wow
glug i've got the best news buddy
it's a word you wouldn't come back i'm
back i'm back look i am back
and i have oh my goodness i have
i have so much ammo for this gun i need
to hurry uh the gas
um yeah the gas i don't need the boots
probably in my base
they're probably fine without it oh wow
you are all dead you're all done
you're dunion rings every last one of
you
is dunzo none of you will survive
sweater seems to be falling apart maybe
the sweater doesn't last forever but
that's okay
and then take the ammo oh my god
click clack clack clack a shackle oh
come at me come at me
oh who's there
who's who's doing that
hey who's there
oh silly silly
oh over there
oh wow why are you covered in the oh
you've got the ooze
you've got the oohs yipes okay
that's fine okay all right
a bit overkill for the huge dogs but
i like it i like it i probably got to be
really careful
because i i legitimately only have so
much of this ammo i've been collecting
it the whole goddamn game and i had no
idea why
but i have it and i can't waste it all
but i can
i can definitely you know have a little
fun
hey stop oh my god get away
stop stop oh all of you oh there's
probably just a bunch of these things
around aren't there
i forgot that i had to clear them out oh
hey mushies uh maybe the
maybe the musician would like you get
stop stop
oh uh look
no oh hey
[Music]
okay okay
i have a feeling that things are gonna
get interesting
uh sell some crap i'll just sell this
single shot shotgun there's no way that
i'm gonna
actually be able to use it i just need
some space i'm gonna sell the other
shovel
shovel shotgun mushy
sell this this if you sold medium
clip i'd be very happy but unfortunate
i need two more weapon parts to be able
to make a shotgun okay so i'm gonna buy
from him now just because if i get
another one of those
then i can make another uh shotgun and
load it up
let's see reload okay
that's all of my shotty gun shells i've
got
medium ammo yeah the assault rifle is
good but it does shoot in bursts
so i need like whatever i pointed at
needs to die quickly
that's what i would use but the pistol
also still has some utility
i mean i could carry all of them i mean
yeah i could
fortnite style this yeah hell yeah
it's got a full loadout why not you know
why not ready for anything
okay uh i think i know what i'm gonna
have to do turn off the generator that's
what i have to do i think i got to go
back to the tree
because i remember there being something
about the old man wanting the tree dead
he said that so there must be some
reason to get an oxygen tank to go there
because it's all flooded in there
so there must be something in there that
i need
that'll help me get to where i need to
go i should talk to the old man again
because i haven't talked to him in a
while let's let's put on uh let's put on
my boots for now because i don't want to
get my
sweater damaged by accidentally hitting
things hello
hi what what are you saying there show
item three boys upon seeing the photo
the [ __ ] cringes with disgust
these ruffians sons of a thief they were
seven of them
the mother took the four youngest one
when the hunger struck
the other three stayed with their father
they were weak and sickly
one day the father got into his head
that they are getting smaller rations
because we've written them off so he
went with a group of people to rob us
of our food in the night they broke into
the basement it didn't end well
the [ __ ] goes silent the lats threw
them out of the village
i don't know what happened to him after
that people used to say they wander the
woods with the savages
looking for their place i can still hear
their cries of that thief
all the bloody time all sorts of things
used to happen in our village
sometimes a mug got punched for some
silly things faint smile appears on the
man's face
but we always stuck together when the
time came
we had to i sometimes hear the echoes of
those times
in the trees moans that [ __ ]
monstrosity won't let me forget
okay but what do i
oh the tree wanted me to do
the ra the radio that's right that was
the whole point
that was whole thing hey
how you doing hello
examine i'm barely able to make out any
conversations
you took everything from us
wait i thought
i thought okay all right then there's
gotta be something here
right there's gotta be something here
that i haven't noticed
i haven't seen i haven't addressed
yet so i've got to find it what is this
[Music]
oh
oh okay
the hole in the wall of the basement it
must have been made by the growing roots
okay
oh who's there ah
um no one what do you want oh nothing
nothing
seller under the oh my feet are slowly
sinking into the soft i can barely move
it's
someone was holding me by the ankles
okay not yet hang on i need to find out
what was it on this other corridor
because i i have to i'm a completionist
like that what was down here
anything just the light the bright light
the light ow the light ow ow
well that would be handy uh thanks for
the ammo
i think they shot themselves i think
that's what that was but i have oxygen
so i can go through here i have two not
on me but i get the other one back home
oh no oh no
oh no so that must be like the whole
thing like if you didn't go through the
dream sequence you had to go through
here and you had to get a whole bunch of
other [ __ ] to do it
basically just like a short okay hey
crates
oh i'm salivating at the thought
oh wait don't where'd my stuff go god
damn it i loaded
i loaded up to the tits because i was
ready for
a fight i probably don't even need the
assault rifle anymore god damn it a huge
rusty barrel judging by the smell
contains a lot of good gasoline inside
great good for that so i'm dreaming am i
oh yeah close that door ah interesting
um
huge rosy barrel judging by the smell
there's a lot of good gasoline
inside right is any one of these like
interactable now is this gonna be a
looping hallway
of course it will what if i go this way
he's locked
all right oh
oh
oh that's a heifer open
um uh uh please open
okay hi
how you doing okay
oh okay hey nothing whoa
hey
oh look at you
ain't you a silly belly a lot of good
gasoline in this barrel
all right see ya see you around kids see
you around
oh
oh an x well thank you for that i'll
equip that immediately because i have a
funny feeling i'm gonna need to use it
huge rusty barrel judging by their smell
contains a lot of good
gasoline but what if okay hear me out
what if i bash this open
oh smart i'm smart i'm smart i'm smart
i'm smart
i'm smart did they give me like just
enough acts to get through
oh this must be
it has to be right
this has to be why they gave me the axe
right no
cat don't tell me i'm just wasting the
axe my giant brain
tells me
right definitely doesn't make sense why
would i would that be the thing that you
would do
i wasted the ax i'm gonna die now hey
hope there's no monsters in here a torch
that's also good like torch
all right i have a torch what if i bash
the last one with a torch would that
work
i have to i have to try i have oh i'd
have to get through this
well here we're gonna find out
nope not gonna do that you know i'm not
gonna do that i have a funny feeling
that's not what i'm supposed to do
oddly enough hmm weird about that and
the way that that is
a makeshift barricade blocking the
entrance to the basement someone or
something is trying to break through
from the other side
interesting okay
[Music]
oh it's open now oh good good good good
good
oh good wish i had my boots
hi
oh oh oh oh
hey wait a minute oh no no you know
oh okay all right well oh
okay
oh more more more
more i want more
more more more yeah
i think it never ends
oh it ends
that was fun oh no don't do this no no
no like this no no not like this
oh no not like this oh no
oh oh i will oh
god it please no i've got powers
i've got powers get [ __ ] with that one
of these
getting a little dark in here
get a little hard to see just a little
okay
all right that was a fun hole let me
tell you what
that hole is grand okay
do i i have my stuff again okay good at
least i got that
ow delight is white
get a torch i don't need a torch you
think i would come down here without
supplies
pile of empty rotten wooden crates
overgrown with small roots oh
good that's handy i could put something
in there why would i
why would i want to oh look the
barrel's valve is rusty but it seems to
be working judging by the smell there's
gasoline inside
wouldn't that just leak gasoline
everywhere let me not do that
yet until i know what i'm dealing with
oh this tunnel looks different it was
carved out by people sloppily and
hastily it's a miracle it still hasn't
collapsed yet
oh oh
the further part of the tunnel is
blocked by rubble looking through a
crack i see a giant pulsating roots
maybe i can find a way to destroy them
yeah i'm thinking the gas
uh if i if i gas it i didn't bring
matches
i didn't think to but i have a torch
that's why it's here
that's why that's here this makes sense
let me just check here first
what do we got here dead end carved out
by roots
all right cool man
oh hey makeshift barricade blocking the
entrance to the basement
okay i guess there's only one thing to
do let me uh just real quick
put this here i guess i don't need my
boots all right open her up
i think right open the valve i grab the
valve and try to turn with all my
strength it suddenly breaks gasoline
starts to leak out of the barrel slowly
flows down the tunnel
oh yeah it does oh yeah it does
bam bam bam baby shroom de wondy
where can i get a good view here oh yeah
give me a give me the view
oh yeah
oh hell yeah maybe i should leave
uh
oh all right if i'm supposed to feel bad
about
burning uh a demon tree i don't
uh i had to kill a whole village of
people just to save a kid
i ain't gonna feel bad about that so
moan all you want
i've done some excessively questionable
things in my adventure here
this is the least questionable oh hey
all right burn baby burn
this the old man will be happy
the huge tree will not yield to the
flame so easily it tries to smother the
fire with its roots it should be all
over tomorrow oh
all right then come here now come
the cripples blind eyes stare hypnotized
at the huge flame consuming the tree
it's as if the old man could see
everything clearly now the orange fire
illuminates his pale motionless face
i'm here now wait you said to come here
now
i'm here now all right
is this gonna light me on fire hey how
you doing
once again i don't feel bad
not at all
this would be where the other is half of
the the hatch would have gone
makes sense makes sense i probably could
have used the axe on the barricade
that's what i could have done
all right anyway see ya see you guys
have fun with that
have fun with that wasn't there more
stuff here in the that i originally went
when i first came here
this is the first place i went and i
never really fully explored it
ow i didn't have my boots where's my
boots
i don't trust them here i i'm poison
protected
you can't hurt me
you can't hurt me you can't hurt me
this is a great day this is a wonderful
day the sounds of a tree dying
oh whoa sounds like someone needs
to taste the shot oh god really
oh really oh you sack
oh you sack oh my god oh my god oh my do
not
you sack i guess i just gotta kill time
until tomorrow
oh the word thieves have been scrolled
i actually do need gas okay and leaving
the village leaving those screams behind
i feel great i feel very accomplished
i feel like everything is wonderful okay
so
i didn't get too many goody goodies i've
got these stupid torches that are just
eating up my
inventory i'll probably need them at
some point but for now
i'm just gonna let them be i need one
more weapon part to make another
pump shotgun which should get me full so
i need to use up this shotgun tonight
and then yeah just wait get cozy hey
how you doing there whoa
whoa
i can't even talk to you what hello oh
my god
are you okay so apparently
it matters what you feed
the musician you're
you're not supposed to feed a mushroom
you're supposed to feed normal food
which i tried to do i tried to give him
a potato
which in my mind is normal food but if
you give him a mushroom
he turns into a monster
that's so unfair like it's fine if it's
if it should be logiced out that maybe
like oh it's like
normal food or mushroom but i tried
normal food
i tried to give him a potato i tried
i feel awful about that i feel awful
i feel [ __ ] terrible i feel like
the problem that i'm having with this
playthrough is that i'm
going through with the best of
intentions i'm trying to do the right
thing
i'm really trying i really am trying
i'm trying
all right i'ma end this one here i think
we're approaching the conclusion but
i've said that so many times now i don't
know how many times more i need to say
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye